i'm sorry that you know like everyone is
a little bit unhappy so people
in west coast are unhappy that it's too
early uh
people on east coast it's the middle of
the lunch people of the
in europe oh it's too late but
nevertheless we have all uh really
exciting uh
great talks here and we have really
great speakers so i hope that
you're you know like that will make uh
us all happier to listen such a exciting
exciting talk so who we have today is
getting and uh
you probably all know getting norman
because of the prism tool
and all his work that he did on a
probabilistic reasoning and
probabilistic model checking
but when i was looking at his biography
i noticed that he was also
behind many many awards that are uh on
the topic of uh verification unless the
randomized as the stochastic systems and
what they found very impressive is that
all of them were rating rated
outstanding up upon their completion so
which i think it's
really great he is right now
a senior lecturer at university of
glasgow
but he uh finished his uh phd in
birmingham
and uh i'm looking forward to his talk
so please uh
the floor is yours but the zoom is yours
yes let me just share my screen okay
so um so maybe excuse me just one
question
do do you want to have interactive so is
it okay
i will just as uh scanned uh if there
are some questions and then
we'll uh ask you would you like to take
questions after the talk
no i'm i'm fine to be so interrupted but
if you just
tell me because it's hard to know i will
pay attention
okay thank you okay so this talk is
about verification and control of
partially observable probabilistic
systems so just to put it
into context with certain videos that i
select prepared so i prepared a sort of
set of videos in
into three parts there was a first part
which just gave you
an introduction into probabilistic
systems and so
the formal verification of them why it's
like we actually do this
then there were two sort of main
main parts to set the videos the first
was on
it's like discrete time markov chains so
here
um these are
like probabilistic systems with in a
discrete time where there's just
slight discrete sort of probability and
i
went into those i sort of
slight defined paths and slight
probabilities and
i explained how to compute both
probabilistic it's like reachability and
expected
reachability select properties and then
i
also explained how these can be used for
site computing it's like the probability
of satisfying ltl
and automated based properties
and then i went on to markup decision
select processes
so here these are like these are
discrete time
it's like markov chains but you also add
in non-deterministic
of behavior and i went through a similar
step process
for those it's like defining
probabilistic
reachability and showing how that can be
used
for more so general ltl and automata
based
site properties so in this third part
what i'm going to talk about are
partially observable it's like
probabilistic systems
and i'll include a a recap of
what you need to know from the videos so
if you haven't
watched them that is not an issue okay
so i'll start just by giving a bit of
our motivation so
often when we want to it's like
guarantee the it's like correctness of
complex systems so we need to take into
account
some quantitative aspects and this
includes
slight probabilities so this could be
due to failure rates or uncertainty
due to um the sensors that we're using
but there's also
so timing it's like characteristics and
good examples of this are in site
communication and
it's like security set protocols where
it's like in order for them to work they
have to have
certain timing or delays so
in order to show they are it's like
correct so you need to like
incorporate that into it's like the
model
now a further slight complication is
that we often also need
a non-determinism so this is where we
don't know
how the system is going to
behave so there might be one or two or
several different
options and so it's like we can't assign
a or it doesn't make sense to assign a
slight probability to them so so
examples of this
is it could be the input
instructions from some external entity
such as a slight controller and it's
also it's like we need
it's like non-determinism when we're
modeling both concurrency and
abstraction
okay now it's like having these three
things
we've we've done in the past we've shown
that we
that we've got automated verification
techniques that have been successfully
it's like used to
so analyzing quantitative properties of
such systems that have so probability
timing it's like characteristics and
non-determinism and
two it's like classical models that
we've used
are markov site decision
processes where there's a discrete
model of time and probabilistic time
automata
where there's a dense or real it's like
model of
site time and we've also got extensions
where we've had sort of more than one
choice of
more than one aspect of it's like
non-determinism and there
it's like we move on to um games
and we've done some recent work on
concurrent stochastic it's like games
now there's two dual slip problems one
is
select the verification and that's
proving that some formerly
specified select property holds
or it's like finding it's like the
optimal
or minimum or some maximum value of some
property and there's the dual slip
problem
is to synthesize the it's like
controller or other strategy
so that's how the non-determinism is are
resolved
in order to it's like guarantee
it's like the value of some um specified
slot property now one thing
that this hasn't taken into our
consideration
is um the extent so to which side the
system state is
observable to the entity that is
are controlling it so for example if you
think about a
a security protocol then if we're trying
to model the
attacker then it can't see
it's like the data that it's going that
it's
like trying to find out about if it
could see the data then
obviously it knows slept what it is so
it
shouldn't be able to observe it when
it's making its
slight choices or trying to attack other
system
it's also if you think about a a robot
that is in some
state environment it can't see the whole
environment it can only use its sensors
so
it's only got a partial view of the
world in order to make it
our decision so if we're going to model
that then in other model
then we also need to model the fact that
the robot
has only a partial view of
other world and there's also a more sort
of
um a third example is
it's like are packets and this is a
psychology example so here when a
scheduler is select choosing how to root
uh
other packets then it can't look at
by the channel state because if it does
that then it will add in
so extra costs and delays
which will cause slight issues
so that's three examples just to show
that we need to take into account
what the controller can observe
so this leads us on to partially
observable
mdps or more shortly
pond dps and this is a slight natural
way to
extend mdps so that we can
take into account this partial
observability in the our discrete time
case so
so one thing to say from the start the
analysis of
upon dps is much more difficult than
it's like mdps and key
so problems are undecidable so that
means that
that we can only get it's like it's like
approximate our results
now i should say that that the use of
pom dps is like common in ai and
planning but they're they're more
interested into our discounted or
finite horizon our problems where things
are actually
are decidable while in a verification
it's normally the case that we
that we're not interested in such
properties we're more
so interested in can we actually get to
a certain
state and the time that it takes is not
as
important so there's been
slight limited um it's like progress in
such a practical are techniques in this
slide area and in this talk i will just
address
some of these slight issues so so what
i'm going to introduce
is techniques for the verification and
our controls so both so the verification
and
strategy are synthesis of
partially observable it's like
probabilistic systems
both under just like discrete and dense
it's like models of slight sign okay and
as i said so the problems are
undecidable so we
are start looking at it's like
approximate
slot analysis and we'll first do so
approximate analysis for
finite state upon dps where there's a
are discrete it's like model of a slight
time so we'll give upper and lower
bounds for looks like the property of
it's like interest in here it's like the
properties are sort of
the minimum and it's like maximum
probability of it's like reaching
targets
or the minimum or it's like maximum
expected it's like cumulative it's like
reward
so before we reach some select target
and these are
like the fundamental it's like
properties in some probabilistic
model checking and we'll also show how
to synthesize
optimal select controllers or our
strategies
and if our upper bounds are
not close enough then we can also are
refined and then try
and get better bounds but we can't it's
like it's like guarantee
that the bands would be better as so
it's undecidable and obviously if we
know that we're going to get
better answer that would mean that we
could
slight decide the problem
okay and that's the first part which we
will which is on a
select discrete stop model of time and
then in the second part i'll move on to
partially observable probabilistic time
automata so here these are it's a
probabilistic time
automata it's like extended to have
partial observability
and there our semantics then yields a
uncountable infinite state
upon dp which is obviously even harder
to solve but here we'll show that
you can use what's called a digital
clocks
discretization and this slip reduces
the analysis analysis to a finite state
of pom dp and then i can use the same
techniques as for the finite state upon
dps
okay so as i outline i'll first go over
mdps then i'll go on to pom dps
we'll have a short break and then i'll
go on to
um probabilistic time automata and
select the parcel observable
probabilistic type
automata and then i'll just mention
something on
sort of implementation and give you some
conclusions okay so first what is a
mark of our decision it's like process
okay so this is a
a model that it's first of all it's in a
discrete time and it has
it's like non-deterministic and
probabilistic a behavior
so it's a a tuple of it's like this for
form so first of all we've got a set of
states or it's like the state space
and we've got some state s 0
that we start in and we've got some
action
alphabet a so these are i'm in some
state and then i can
i i can can so i perform some
subset of some actions
next we've got what is the partial
probabilistic transition a relation
so here given any state and
slow action this um function might be
are defined if it is then that means
that that action
can be it's like performed in that state
and if it is undefined then this gives
us a a distribution
so that tells us what the next state
will be with what a probability and then
it's like the final part is a slight
reward
it's that function that says that it if
i'm in a state and i
so i perform an action what is the
reward that is
it's like accumulated so here is
an example mdp so we've got the states
the
um actions
are labeling the transitions and so are
there
by rewards so let's give an example okay
so
in each state s there is a a
non-deterministic choice so
what choice is what action do i
perform select next and this is over
it's like the actions for which the
slight distribution is
the probability the transition just like
distribution is
select defined and if we choose action a
then so we'll move to state t with this
our probability here so here if we look
at state
s one we've got two actions that are
available b and c if we perform b
then we'll either go to state s so 0
with
probability 0.7 or we'll stay in s
s 1 with some probability 0.3 and if we
do choose b then we just like accumulate
the
select reward 1.3 on the other hand if
we've chosen
action c then we'll either go to s2 or
s3 each with
slight probability 0.5 and we will just
like accumulate the
select reward to 2.8
okay so from this we can then say what
paths are in an
mdp so this is just a it's like sequence
of states
and the actions so you're in a state you
choose
an action so it's like we need this to
be
are defined for each si and ai so we can
actually do that
select action and then by the next state
so we have to get here with some
probability it's not greater than zero
so so in each case so the probability if
i'm in state i
and i choose action ai then the
probability that i move to state
s i plus one must be it's like greater
than
zero so if we think of a path then it
both resolves the uh it's like
probabilistic
and the non-deterministic choices so we
choose both
it's like the action which is resolving
it's like the non-deterministic choice
and then we choose the following
successor state so that then also it's
like
resolves the non-deterministic choice
now if we just consider a our strategy
which is also called a either a a
scheduler or a
a controller or a adversary but i'll
stick to
strategy so here this is a
resolution of the non-determinism
only so how does this work so
given any a finite path or it's like
history
then the strategy says what action do i
do
on next so it's just given any path it
will
i return what action is i performed
and then if we're under a our strategy
then
the behavior of an mdp is
fully a probabilistic okay so this
it actually gives you a
it's like discrete time it's like markov
chain
and if we've got a our strategy then we
can reason about
the probability of events
it's like overpass so if you've got a
strategy
then we can talk about what's the
probability
of a path it's like reaching a certain
goal set
okay so the two properties i'm gonna
i'll consider
uh probabilistic and it's like expected
by reachability and these are the
fundamental to
select concepts inside quantitative
verification
so all the sort of ltl and
automata based are properties uh
it's like involves some sort of graph
based
slight analysis and then it's like
reduced to
some form of um computing
so optimal reachability of values
so we've got if we've got a our strategy
then we've got a
our dtmc and we can talk about what's
the probability of
it's like reaching some just like target
t
under a slight strategy of sigma
and similarly we can talk about
what's the expected it's like reward
that is accumulated
so before we reach a select target set t
under the strategy of sigma however
we've got a sort of
eight there's a infinite number of it's
like
slight strategies so what we consider is
it's like the optimal which can either
be it's like the minimum or
are the maximum it's like value over all
possible our strategies
and as i said this is it's like
fundamental so
just from from this we can then do
automata based and also other
reward based of properties
and just to say that there are
it's like efficient algorithms and
it's like tools for tool support
for this and uh for example
if um prism uses
so value iteration for the our
computation
and we can compute both the optimal
select value and also a optimal
strategy so this is a our strategy under
which
we achieve it's like the optimal of
value
and just to say that the that
we can return a it's an optimal our
strategy
that that it picks a action
in each state with a probability one
and it it doesn't need to look at other
history so it's
a memoryless it it can just base its
choice
on the on the sort of final state of the
past so given any two
any two paths that end in the same state
it
would make the same choice for um
for those two select parts
so there's much more our detail on this
inside the video
are lectures for parts one and part
two so there's one more thing that we
need on
mdps so this again is in
other videos so here how do we actually
compute these
values so this is the case for expected
or reachability so if you've got some
value a function that goes from the
states to
the reals then to compute the optimal
expected it's like reachability of
values
we can just are repeatedly
it's like compute these so this is a
recursive
so so the value in state s is
are dependent on that in them in state t
so how does this work okay so first if
so if we're in some state that is in
other target then
then we've reached other target and it's
like we're not gonna
accumulate any a reward so the reward is
are zero and if we haven't reached
by the target then we can look for each
slot action we've got the slight reward
that we
it's like accumulate when we perform
that action so we're in state s
so we perform it's like action a so this
is the reward that we
just accumulate then if we
um make a our transition to
state t then this is the probability
that we move to t
because we're in s and we perform a and
then
this is um
that expected a reward from
from from state t and if we sum
over all um t then this gives the
expected select value um
under the assumption that we perform a
and s so since we do this
for for each slot action and so we want
it's like the optimal then we either
take the min or
it's like the max of it's like
like this so if we do this then under
certain
our restrictions which i won't go into
here
then if we just keep doing this then
this will
select converge to the optimal
expected uh reachability set values
for all slight states
and the case for it's like probabilistic
it's like reachability is it's almost
the same so
in this case if we reach the
if we're in the our target then
obviously that we reach it with
our probability one so this would be one
and then we just don't have this part
here as we're only interested in
select probabilities okay so that's
mdp so now let's go on to our pom dps
so these just these are
mdps that but they are extended
by restricting
the extent to which the current state
can be
observed by the by a our strategy
and so that can change this will
influence
the choices that it can make so there's
several different notions of what can be
observed so uh here i'll choo i've
chosen
the simplest but most are
equivalent so if you can use one form
then
you can rewrite the pom dp it's like to
use it's like the other form of
observability so what is a
upon dp well it's a
tuple similar to an mdp so we still have
this
um so we have the first lot of
elements are the same as we have in an
mdp so we've got
a state space we've got an initial state
we've got a set of
slot actions we've got the probabilistic
transition our relation
which is again it's like partial and
we've got
the reward step function so given a
state and
action it tells you what is the reward
is
slightly accumulated and what is
added in is we've got the set o of which
is
a finite set of observations and then we
have this
function that says if i'm in say
s what which of the observations do i
see
okay so now a our strategy
doesn't see a a state it only sees
what is observable so this is it's like
applying
the this observation
function to a state so there's one
technical a requirement and that says
that for
observationally slight equivalent states
the same actions must be
available so so this is so
for any states s and s prime
what is observable
has to be the same if they have the same
action so why is this well if the action
set was
are different then other strategy could
see the two different
see that two different action sets were
available
and then obviously it would be able to
tell you that the states weren't
weren't the same because you could do
slight different things in those two
slight slight states so
for upon dps for parts and
strategies they just carry over are
directly there isn't anything
that changes for paths and select
strategies
however there is a a restriction on the
class of
such strategies that are used for select
mdps
and the class that i used a lot called
observation based
strategies so these must make the same
choices if it's observed the same thing
because
as far as other strategies are concerned
it's in the same place because it isn't
observed the same
thing so there could be two parts um if
that
observation it's not equivalent then it
has to do
the same thing so what does it mean to
be
observationally equivalent so if you've
got two parts pi
and pi prime then they're
observationally equivalent
if each of the states yields the same
observation and each of
the actions is also the slight saying
so under the our requirement that means
that any
um observation based
strategy would have to make the same
choice in pi and
pi prime because it would have observed
the same
the the same thing
so just to say that there are that we
can find
as or we can look for
optimal um our strategies for
probabilistic and expected reachability
for
upon dps but now they need to know
they're no longer on memoryless as
it's like they need to look at other
history
as what they've now observed
in the past can give them some
information
as to what state they currently think
they are in as
we will see but they can but they're
still
are deterministic so they still only
there's no need for
a randomization so let's
just give a simple example just to see
what is going on
so this is a simple amaze so say that a
a robot was randomly placed
into one of these slight grids and then
try to reach
select the target or location let's say
which i've i'm colored in it's like
it's like red here so and then and
so it's in it's like one of these grids
and it can try and move in four
different
or it can try to move in four different
directions but
obviously for example if it was in grid
one
it it it could only go either east
or up west now
all that the robot can see is
um the walls that
are surrounded so it doesn't know that
i'm in grid five or i'm in grid a
all that it knows is that i'm in a grid
square and there's a wall so here if i
was in five or eight and all that i
could see was
there was a wall to the east and
to the west and there was no wall either
um
to the north or to the so let's set so
it wouldn't
be able to tell if it was in state 5 8
sorry 5 6 7 8 9 or attacked so
if it was placed in it's like either of
these are squares
then it wouldn't know or where
it was so if it was going to try to get
to the goal
for um then it wouldn't know if it was
in so either of these
so obviously if it was in for example if
it was in five then
it's it's like best to move up while if
it was in six
it would be better to move down because
you're getting closer
to the goal but there's more there's a
if it was
randomly placed in the grid then there's
a higher chance that it's either in five
or
seven so so the optimal thing
is to move up so even though in
in stage six it would be better to move
down it doesn't know that it only knows
if it's in
one of these six states
now if it moved up then
it would see these two walls here and it
would now know that it was in state
are zero and it could now go uh directly
to the goal similarly if it was in six
then it would move up to two and this is
it's like the only grid square with just
a wall
to the it's like north so it would know
that it was in two
so it would then go backwards and head
to
um the goal so
let's just i've already said so it turns
out
that the optimal time to um optimal
or so minimum slight number of such
steps
so to reach the target is
5.23 and this is for a
strategy of the upon dp now
if we were to turn it into a so mdp
which meant that the robot could always
see
it's like where it was then the steps
the optimal number of such steps it
decreases to 4.0
as and we will come back to this
okay so how can we compute these are
valid
their optimal select reachability cert
values for
just like it's like pom dps
so as i i previously said these
problems are actually and
so this means that we can't really think
that we're going to be able to compute
exact our solutions
now a useful construct is what's called
a
belief mdp so this is a
fully observable mdp which has the same
optimal probabilistic and it's like
expected it's like reachability
select values as the upon dp
however this comes at a cost so so we
don't just get to move to a
select finite state mdp which has the
same
select values as then it would be easy
to so compute the values of
the pom dp so this has to come at a cost
and this comes at the cost that the mdp
that we go to is a has a continuous
and it's like accountable state space
and so the states are what called
such beliefs so these are probability
such distributions over the state space
of
the original pom dp
so the intuition here is in a
slap pom dp we may not know what state
we are in
however we have observed certain things
it as we've moved through this the
um as we look at as we performed
actions and so we also know
it's like the structure of the it's like
palm dp
so as we observe things
we can determine it's like the
likelihood of which state we
are in and we update this as as we
change
slight state
so let's see how
we can use this to select construction
certain like probabilities in this
it's like select belief mdp
so let's so let's say that we're in some
our belief be so this is a our
distribution over the states
that we could be in and
and we and there's some observation oh
and it's like action a
okay let me just so first of all
let's look at
if we're in the our belief um b
and what's the probability that we
observe um o after
slip filming the action a and b so this
is given by this
our formula here so why is why
why does this work first of all let's
look at this here
so this is that so say the way say that
we were in state
s and we perform a then this is like the
probability
that we reach t so if we do the
summation over all states that have the
observation o then this gives us
like the probability of observing o
from s when we perform a so
if we're in s and we perform a
and this is it's like the probability
that
we've reached t so we just sum over all
the t
where we observe o
and then this is the belief
that we were in so this is b so this is
like the probability
that we're actually in s and then we sum
over all the states
that we could have been in when we
perform a so this
it's like indeed gives us like the
probability of
observing o outperforming action a in
a belief b okay so that's the first part
the second part so say that we were in b
we perform a and we observe o
what what then is what how do we
update our of belief where do we now
believe
that we are so we need to update
it's like the probabilities of what
state we think
that we are in and this is how we update
that so let's go through
again why this works
okay so first so first this is now going
to be after we've done a
and o from the belief b this is
like the probability that we now believe
that we're in
state two okay so first of all
this is after observing o
so if if if
in state t we don't observe o then we
can't be in it because we
or so the probability that we believe
that we're in it is going to be
it's like zero because we do observe o
so what happens when we if in state t
we do observe
o so first of all so
let's look at say that we were in some
some state s
so this is slight problem
the probability that we were in s it's
like before
we select before so i performed a
and saw o and this is
select the probability
that from um that that from this state s
we just perform action a and we do
indeed reach the state t
and then we sum over all of the states
that we could have been in when it's
like performing
a so this gives us like the probability
of
it's like reaching t from the belief b
when we perform a so this is the top
half of the
a fraction and then it's like the bottom
half
is like what we had our previously so
this is
the probability of observing o after
performing action a
in our belief so if
so we end up with this
it's like fraction here and if you think
about this for
a a minute we've got a
it's like common part to it which is
when we're in b
and we perform a and this is of
observing o and this is
it's like reaching t and observing oh
so this is it's like the probability of
it's like reaching t from b
when performing a and it's like
conditioned on
observing o so this is indeed
the belief reached after we perform a
and we observe o
so it's like the final thing that we
need which is much simpler
is the reward that we accumulate
after performing action a in it's like
belief b
so here let's look at this so this is we
were in b so this is
we're in the belief b so this is like
the probability that we're actually in
state
s this is the reward that we
would have accumulated if we were in s
and then we sum
over all the states that we could have
been at so this
does indeed gives us the reward that is
slightly accumulated after performing
action a
in a belief b so why haven't
i uh so introduce these three things
well that's because they're going to be
used in start performing
value so iteration over the
it's like belief mvp so this is
um this is for an mdp
this was the main step of the value it's
like iteration
okay now for the belief
mdp we end up with this
slap formula here which changes us
slightly so let's just go through how it
our changes
so first whereas for a usual
mvp we base it over the
our successor states now we're doing it
over the
um what we observe
and then we use the reward slot
accumulated after forming action a
in our belief b
and then we use this probability of
observing oh after performing action a
in
our belief be and then we use
it's like we're now in this uh our
belief here
so we now look for it's like the value
of this
belief which is the belief that we reach
from b
after performing a so we've
chosen a from this set and we observed o
so it's the belief that we reach after
sub performing a and observing
o okay so that's
so that's so this is what we would like
to do
okay but this is over our beliefs
um so this is the set of our
distributions over
other state space so that there are
uncountably it's like many our beliefs
so it's that we obviously can't start to
do
value iteration over all of them okay
so what we can do is a resort to a
our approximate our solution of the
belief
mdp so we just take a a representative
set of
our beliefs so let's call them g1
up to g and and so the one
slight requirement it's like we need is
that they for
is that they are um that their
our convex hell is the full set of um
our distributions so that exists our
constants
so that if we take a sum using the
it's like constants we can generate any
other
distribution and i'll soon show you why
we need this
so which is
it's like what this does okay so it's
like
what we need is interpolation so given
an a so arbitrary
our belief or our distribution then we
need to find real
it's like constants let's call them
gamma 1
up to gamma n so that we can write the
arbitrary our distribution as a sum
over these representatives
representative
of beliefs okay and this works because
we
are required it to be a a convex health
so we can always find these
our constants gamma 1 up to gamma m
so in the implementation i'll say
a a bit more about a
it's like concrete example of
this okay so how can we use these
so it's like what we're going to do is
do
a value iteration but just over the
our beliefs g1
up to gn so let's take one of other grid
points let's say
gi then value iteration for this
so this i've just just plugged it into
what i showed you
up before and what i've also it's like
it's like showing you is that we can
easily i'll compute this
also this value here and
we can also compute this
our belief here now and
so we also know that o is the set of
observations is
finite and also the set of actions is
finite
so this all looks good however this
our belief here there is no reason for
this to be a
a grid point so there's no reason
why we know it's our value so this is
this is the it's like belief
reached from a a grid point
that we know gi after after after
performing
a and observing o so if o is
um a our target then
so we do know it but if it isn't then we
don't know
it's like what the answer is so
now from the interpolation
we know that we have these are constants
gamma 1 up to gamma n
and we can write gr this
our belief using these
our gammas and we do know are the values
for
g1 up to gn so we can
therefore approximate this
set the value for it's like this one
using these
are constants here now there's no a
reason why this will
so equal this so this is an
approximation
however um
it has been proved that value
iteration does are converge
if we take this slight approach and
i'll show you also that it also
yields sort of upper bounds so
if we find these our values
so this will actually converge
then so after that then we can
synthesize what i've put in
sort of it's like quotes as
it's like optimal because it's based on
these are values which are
approximate so that means that it's not
actually the optimal but
it it so i i put it in it's select
quotes we can generate a
finite memory our strategy so we can
step through the
upon dp and base our
optimal select choices on
this so we're in some current
our belief and then we can choose some
action to
our perform and that will update our our
beliefs so we'll move
somewhere else how do we choose it's
like the optimal
value what we use these are values
that we have so we
it's like approximate the
our belief that we would have it's like
it's like reached
so what happened so if we do this then
we can generate a
our dtmc and
we can find out what what the values are
for this
um in quote it's like optimal uh
our strategy so let's put all this
so it's like before
i put this all together just
it's like one thing in practice
what we're not so interested in is just
it's like saying
well all of the probabilities are select
between some
it's like minimum or on maximum okay
that's
not really what happens in our practice
what we're usually interested in is just
one of uh
it's like the optimal values so
for example if you're looking at it's
like worst case
slight analysis then it's like you want
to know what's the maximum it's like
probability of
an error or the expected time or slight
cost it's not really interested to
to know what the minimum probability of
an error is julie it's like we
want to know what's the minimum slight
probability that a
our message arrives or what's the
minimum
it's like profit of our our system
on the other hand for it's like
controller
it's like synthesis it's like it's like
we want the dual thing
we want the our controller that so it
maximizes
sorry that minimizes the probability of
an error
or the time or it's like cost or the
controller that
maximizes the probability that a
select message slot arrives but but we
don't
but it's like what we're not interested
in is
that the values are set between the
minimum and the
maximum so let's go back and put these
things
up together so let's look at the case
for
probabilistic select reachability so say
that we wanted to know
so these are the actual minimum and our
maximum
for the upon dp and we'll be only
interested in
it's like it's like one of these okay so
if we use this grid to do it's like the
value
it's like iteration then that gives us
an over
approximation so so the minimum that we
would get
from the grid is actually less than or
equal to
or the minimum the actual a minimum
while are the maximum is actually
greater than or equal to
it's like the actual or maximum and then
we can also let's synthesize this
um it's like it's like optimal
our strategy now this is a our strategy
of the
upon vp so that means that it has to be
so
it's our value is greater than or equal
to the actual
a minimum and it and if we've done uh
so the maximum then it has to be less
than or equal to the actual
it's like maximum so this then gives us
these
two-sided bands because as i sort of
said we would only be interested
in this case here or in
like this case here and not that it was
between the maximum and
by the minimum here so by getting these
our two-sided bands
we actually get some good if
these bands are it's like relatively
tight then that gives us
it's like the information that we need
now if the bands um are to our course
then we can change our grid so we can
try to refine our grid so add extra
our grid points and then try again now
since so the problem is undecidable
so we can't it's like guarantee that
this will yield
just like it's like tighter bounds
all that we can say is that as the grid
goes to
infinity so as we add once we add in all
other grid points then we'll get the
right answer so it will converge
eventually but we can't say anything
more than that because it's an
undecidable our problem
okay so the final thing before a a break
so
just to give you something a bit less
it's like technical so let's look at the
dining cryptographers
problem so here we've got n
cryptographers that are going to share a
a meal and the meals either paid for by
are the master or
one of the cryptographers and it's so
the master who
decides who slept pays and
each cryptographer is told sort of in
isolation if um either so the master
will pay or
if it's like one of those will one of
the cryptographers will
start pay and the goal is that the
cryptographers
would so i'd like to know if it was
either
it's like the master that paid or it was
one of them
sells but they don't want to know which
one of them
it's like it's like it's like paid
so chow came up with a uh
solution to here is for three
cryptographers
so each cryptographer flips a coin so
this is the coin of the
first one this is of the third and this
is of by the second
and they only tell their left
it's that neighbor so the value of the
top of the coin
so the first one does tell the third one
but it doesn't tell the
second one so only the third and the
first one can see
the first um the coin of cryptographer
slow one
so they look at the two coins that they
can see
so for example [ __ ] talk for one can see
its coin and the coin of crypto for two
and then if they are not are paying
then they'll say i agree if the coins
are the same
and select disagree if they're not on
the other hand
if um a cryptographer is like paying
then it will say the opposite so it
it will say so i disagree if the coins
are the same
and it's like agree it's like otherwise
okay so it's been proved that this is
this yields a it's not correct
a slight solution so um
there's a odd number of our degrees if
the master pays while a even number if
the
if a cryptographer paid while
it's well anonymity is
reserved okay so it's like neither of
the non-paying
our cryptographers or anyone else can
find out who
actually select pays
so just to say that i did do this
analysis of this using mdps
and it did work but it it
it took two two to the power n select
properties
um using mdps and it is a hack
i can say that as i actually did it
while
now that we've got slip on dps in
prism then the model is much easier and
more
are straightforward and um
so here what i've done
is um that one of the our cryptographer
guesses who who pays after
the announcement when we
assume that one of the other end it's
like minus one
um was like chosen to pay at
it's like random and obviously now it's
not a hack so let me quickly show you
how this works and then we'll have a
it's like it's like break so let me
share my actual screen now
so um
[Music]
so the first thing just to quickly show
you
of the model this is in it's like the
prism a language so we've got that it's
a
upon dp some of other variables of the
system
can be seen and some can't so we first
got
that the master either chooses that the
first or or the second one pays
and then we've got that each of the
cryptographers flips a coin and then
does its
slight announcement and then for
the third one as this is the one that is
it's like going to guess so after all
the announcements hit them it's like
guesses
who it's actually paid and we've got a
a property file somewhere so we're first
going to show that it's
that it's um that so here we've got that
it's
one of the our cryptographers page
so it should only be an even number of
slight degrees and then we're going to
find out what's the maximum select
probability
that the other crypto cryptographer can
guess it's like correctly so if it is
anonymous then except the maximum slot
probability
should be point and five so let's now
actually
do this so we'll first do the first
slight select property so just to show
so say this is it feels builds a upon dp
does the grid based slot analysis and
then afterwards
builds a strategy and then
analyzes it's like the corresponding um
dtmc so here we find out that the outer
bound is point one and
so is so the inner band so we get the
correct
answer as the two bounds are the same
and
we would get what we would hope that
indeed so
the protocol is are correct so
if we now go on to the second slide
so you won't understand what the grid
it's like resolution means now
but you will it's like later but
resolution so if you start with a
very small grid then we do
the analysis and we don't get very tight
up back so
all that we know now is that
that the probability is like it's like
between 0.5
and 0.1 so if we change the
resolution then we can end up with
the correct answer so it's like we know
that the answer is it's like between
point five
and point five therefore it's 0.5 okay
but since it's an undecidable thing we
can try a
a different grid and we can actually end
up
it's like again with um not typed
select bands okay so so the final thing
to say for
this one is that we can turn it into a
mdp so we can make everything
observable and if we now find out what's
the probability that the
our cryptographer can guess it's like
correctly
well now it can see it's like everything
so obviously it can guess with
it's like it's like probability one okay
so the final thing
in the our demo i will go back to the
maze
example so this is it's like the maze so
here
it can only it's
so the robot is it's initially it's like
randomly placed
in the maze and then it can move but
it can only see
the observable and not the actual
state so we have these different
observables as to which walls
it can see so if we run that now
and we try that with a grid let's just
try it something then we can see that
that here so we actually get the
perfect answer so let's try it with a
smaller one
just to show you that we don't always
get the right answer so here
we can see that it's that we only get
it's like
an approximate uh a result okay and we
can do the same thing
in that we can turn it into a mdp
so now it's like the robot can see it's
like where it is
and if we do it now then we get
a precise a result
okay so i will now
so i'll stop sharing and we can now have
a break for five or ten minutes
yes are there maybe quick questions that
someone would like to ask
right now or
so i can ask a good question please anna
uh hi um so i see that there is a
different time when you when you compute
approximate bounds and
uh exact an exact solution and it's
always the case that the exact
exact solution i think takes longer
unless it's an mdp
so can you comment on that so it's like
is it easier to compute approximate
bounds in terms of what you mean by
the approximate so so you have
so you have the exact solution when the
bounds correspond to each other so when
they match
and then you have some approximate
solution when it's uh four point five
and five
five point three yeah yeah
yeah it's always shorter uh in terms of
time
not always because i stopped
when we got it's like based on it's like
the number of
it's like grid points so if there's more
it's like grid points then you've got to
compute more it's like values during
value
it's like iteration so it will then if
it will then take it's like longer
for the same probably the same
slight problem but there's no it's like
guarantee
because it's all on also the it's like
convergence
liquid how it are converges so it's sort
of
it's both dependent on
the number of grid points and what the
grid points are
and are they close to the beliefs that
you actually
it's like it's like want to be it and as
i say
it's like towards the end it's sort of
this is a quite a
it's like naive it's like approach where
you just
fix the grid points but yeah yeah
yeah this was my concern this was my
concern that uh it's probably very
dispersing in how how fast it goes
when it's approximate solution and can
it be the case that
if we have a certain belief we can
actually
stop at some point and say okay we're
happy with this approximate solution and
we are not going to
explore anymore other beliefs for
example
or the rest of the greed or something
so you need to do it for all for all of
the
states
it could be that someone it's like
reachable so they're not used so
yeah it's yeah yeah so so i can in
principle throw them away and
just say okay i'm happy with this one
yeah and that is what we actually do in
our practice so we look to see if it's
actually
it's like used and if it isn't then we
don't but it is very
unnaive it's like we haven't really had
a chance to go on to sort of
it's like it's like optimizing this
which is
one of the reasons i've so focused on
this as it's
work that i would like to take forward
so
okay okay thanks okay
uh maybe let's take a break until uh
well in for next six minutes so we start
at 45 whatever is your time zone so that
we also gave a
getting a chance to get the cup of
coffee and uh
okay great thank you
you
so
uh
uh
great tutorial thank you very much kevin
it's really exciting and interesting uh
let me ask one question while it's
actually more
like understanding question it is um
when you compute beliefs are you always
guaranteed to uh converge on the values
uh using so the grid based yes
it's been put luckily someone in the
past proved that
that these two are converge and that
they converge to sort
to over slight approximations so
it's very involved
i was just wondering because you know
like
it wasn't very intuitive but okay if you
say it's very well proved
it's understanding when someone who is
not in this field it's not intuitive am
i you will be able to compute but yeah
thank you okay so it looks that uh
everyone is back so would you we shall
continue then be the second part of your
tutorial
okay
okay so
so in the first part it was all about a
a discrete
it's like model of it's like time so
here what i'm going to do is
move to a dense or what
our continuous it's like model of it's
like time
so let me just get it to check okay so
first
uh so as i said so we're now going to
have a dense time
our domain so we're going to take the
non-negative
it's like reals so our time now is over
the non-negative it's like it's like
reals and we'll
assume that we've got a finite set of
clocks that we'll call
x and each clock little x
is a slight variable
that takes time it's like value so
their values from our time our domain
and we will assume that all clocks
increase at at the same rate as
it's like real time so they act like
clocks
and we also just assume that we can
re uh set them so we can set them to
a slight zero and what a clock
our valuation does is it just
so it tells us what's the value of all
of the clocks at a
current time point okay so it's just a
a vector over over the clocks
okay and then if some time a passes then
it's like obviously all of the clocks
should increase
by that time so if the clock evaluation
was v
and t time it's like units pass then we
should move to this clock
evaluation here v plus t so for each
clock
x it's our value was
just like what it was so v of x
and then t time units have passed so the
clock
increases um by t time
slight units what we also need are
zones over clocks so these i will
are denoted by zones of x so these are
these we can consider as
as a subclass of
it's like polyhedra so these are sort of
like when
these gives us our conditions when all
the clocks are in
um satisfy certain our constraints
then we can do it's like certain things
or we can't do
our certain things so we can say sort of
that a clock is
less than or equal to some um
integer it's that value or uh it's like
greater than or equal to some
it's an integer it's not value
we can compare the clocks we can take
our negations and we can add these
clock it's like constraints or zones so
we can sort of say
clock x is like less than or equal to
four
and clock y is like greater than or
equal to seven
okay and then we say that a clock
evaluation satisfies a zone is
if the zone is true after we
for each x it's like we substitute in
the actual
slight value from the clock
it's like evaluation v
so we can now use these
it's like concepts to so introduce
probabilistic timed
automata so these you can either think
of these as
mdps plus real are valued clocks
or you can think of them as timed
automata
plus slight discrete
probabilistic choices okay and so this
gives us now a it's like model that has
problem probabilistic non-deterministic
and now
sort of real time of behavior
so what is a a pta so at first it looks
a bit
uh it's complicated it's quite a long
tuple so let's go through what each part
is so first we've got a finite set of
our locations so these are sort of these
you can think of these as sort of
the current
state absent of what our clock
our values are so we've got a finite set
of our locations and we start
in some slight initial
our location l is like zero
we've then got as for mdps we've got a
seven
actions that we can perform
and now and we've also got it's like
clock so
a actual state is now
the our location that we're in but also
a um it also says
it's like the value of all the
it's like clocks x so it's a
our location plus a clock slot valuation
and then we have these three different
are functions so first
we have a invariant our condition so
this says
it's like what the values of the clocks
have to be
to be in a certain location so
um so it goes from
our locations to zones or it's like
clock
our constraints so that says
the condition on what the clocks
have to satisfy to be in a a location
then we have a it's like enabling our
function
so this says if i'm in a a location
can i currently perform a given slight
action
so given a a location and
it's like action then it receive it
so it returns a it's like clock
constraint or zone that says
what has to be it's like satisfied in
order for that so action to be
are taken and then we've got a
probabilistic transition slot function
so this says
if i'm in a a location and i
can perform an action and i do
then this tells me uh
it's like the probability that i just
reset
some set of clocks and i move to some
other
location and finally we've got a
select reward structure which both gives
us
a slight reward over the
our locations and a slight reward over
it's like the actions and i will come
back to how
these work so let's just first give you
a very simple
example to give you sort of more
understanding so here's a like simple
it's like probabilistic communication uh
select protocol so we start in some our
location
d i so in the initial our location we
start with all the clocks
it's like equal to zero so say that so
let's start with that we've just got a
clock x so now if we look
then we've got an invariant for our
location
d i that says that x has to be less than
or equal to two
so it's like we have to leave d
i it's like before x is
it's like greater than two and x is a
clock so it
um so it increases at the same rate as
it's like it's like real time so we have
to leave it after
um by the time that two time units have
slept past and then we've got this one
slight action which is
send and we can only take this
after x is select greater than or
equal to one so if we combine that
invariant and the guard
then it follows that we have to take the
send
so action set between uh one and two
time slight units
so after we do the send slot action
then with select probability 0.9 we'll
move to the
location sr and i haven't put any clocks
that are it's like reset here so we just
move to this our location and x would
keep the same
slight value that it had just like
previously
on the other hand with probability point
point one then we move to the location s
i
and we reset the clock x so
we'd move to s i and the clock x would
now take value
it's like zero and then it would start
to increase
again from zero at the same rate as
real our time so if we now also look at
si so here we have the invariant
x is less than or equal to three and the
guard
um
sorry but enabling slight condition x is
greater than or equal to two so this
means
in s i it's like between two and three
time
uh our units we just attempt to
select retry and it's like we either go
to
sr or with probability point zero
point zero five we would go back to s i
x would get
reset and then we would do the same
thing
over so if we failed then we try again
so between two or three
and if he fell again then we'll try
again it's not between two or three
times
our units and so on
okay so just one extra thing to say here
is that if we added
an extra clock here y that so here it
would start from
select zero here and if we didn't i re
reset it on either of these then this
would
and we put this extra our condition here
on the enabling our condition
then we could only take this retry
in the case that less than 10 time units
had elapsed since the system
it's like started okay so that's just to
show you
that there's more it's like going on
than just having this one clock
x right so that's
a it's an intuition so let's now give
the formal
our semantics which is an infinite state
mdp so here as i've sort of said
the states of the mdp give a
our location and then a
select valuation to the clock so it's a
our location clock a select valuation
slot pair and it it
has to be such that the invariant of the
a location
is satisfied by the clock
of valuation because we can only be in
that
a location when this slight invariant is
are satisfied
and the initial state of of the mvp
is just the initial our location with
all the clocks set to
are zero and
what uh the actions well here they
are um time
and actions from the
select pta so they're pairs of the form
ta
so we let some time pass and then we
perform some
[ __ ] action a
and we need some obviously there's some
our requirements on it
given that we've got it's like
invariants and guards and
it's like we need to follow certain
probabilistic transition slight
function so first if you're in state lv
then we can choose a time
t and an action a and we have a our
non-deterministic choice
it's like over this and this can be over
an infinite set of time slot action
pairs as
time is over it's like the reels
and we require first of all that while
time
slip passes the invariant slight remains
satisfied
so it's it's like continuously
satisfied during during time t so
the evaluation plus t prime
satisfies a invariant for all t
prime so between zero and t
then we need to be able to take a so
that means that we need a to b
it's enabled after the t select timer
units have
slight past so it has to satisfy that so
v plus t has to satisfy the enabling
our condition given that i'm in l and i
i'm trying to
cite the form a and then so finally so
we need to satisfy the probabilistic
transition
select function so that means if we
choose a then
so the probability of start moving to a
location l prime
and set and resetting some set of clocks
y
then this is given by the probabilistic
transition slope function so
just to show you a example
it's like execution so if we resolve all
of
other non-determinism then we're going
to get a our dtmc
so we start with the clock x equal to
zero
we could choose to lay one point one
time
it's like units pass then do send so we
would first
move here and then x would be equal to
one plus one
and then we would do the send so we'd
either end up in sr
and x would be 1.1 because we don't
reset x or we'd move to s i and x would
be
equal to zero since we do reset it here
and then in sr it's like we might choose
to let some time
time pass and here it can be any slight
amount of time
greater than or equal to one so we
choose 8.66
then we would set x x would then be
it's not zero because we do it's like
it's like reset
and we've got a similar thing here so
that's just to show you
how it works so
so finally on the our semantics how do
the
select rewards here where we have two
different
rewards we have our location it's like
rewards
and these are sort of as time
the more time that surpasses the more
that these um
accumulate so that um
the our location rewards says
the rate at which the reward is slightly
accumulated so
if we spent time t and our location
um l then it would be
r it would be this it's like value times
t
that would be the reward that we would
actually
accumulate and then so the action are
rewards they are
instantaneous so they just sort of if i
i'm in um
a location l and i perform a
then i get this instantaneous
reward so i'll just
mention that these um
so the this is actually the
probabilistic extension of what are
called
linearly linearly priced timed automaton
which are also called weighted time or
automaton
okay so that's general our semantics but
we've got
an issue in that we've we in our
state spaces and are countable okay
the states are clock our valuation pair
is lv
and v is over it's like real
uh our values however
we could so consider just certainly
digital clocks
are semantics so this is where clock so
digital clocks
mean what you would think they can only
take it's like integer
or digital slope
value so this means that we sort of
changed the time our domain
from the reals to a subset of the
unnaturals
and what's been shown is that
the digital clocks semantics yields a
finite state
mdp which is like preserves both
optimal probabilistic and expected
it's like reachability our values
under the requirement that all the zones
are closed
so there's no uh strict
inequalities and you can't compare
slap clocks so all of those sort of our
components
in the zone are either a clock exit it's
like greater than or equal to some value
or
less than or equal to some value in both
such cases so the value has to be and
integer
and it's like we don't need to take the
full set of
um our naturals is that we can bind
the clocks by k max plus one
where this is like the maximum
it's like constant that is in other pta
so
if we do this then we get a it's like
finite state
mdp and then we can use the analysis are
techniques
that i introduced so earlier
and if it's closed and are diagonal free
then we actually get the correct
our values for the our pta
and it's sort of it's the original
semantics over the reels
and if we take this slight approach
then select automatic
so analysis of our ptas
exists so we can give
a our pta our specification
if it's closed and are diagonal free
then it can use this
so create a finite state mdp do
the analysis and just like return the
correct it's like optimal
it's like probabilistic or select
reachability of values
so this these might sound like quite
strong
it's like restrictions but in some
practice we've seen that there are many
are case studies that affect this
but it can lead to if if this k-max is
like large it can lead to large
mdps but
prism has a sort of a our symbolic
engine and we've been able to so
[Music]
analyze mdps with hundreds of or
millions of
it's like states start using this
slight approach okay so i'll just
mention that there are alternatives for
um analyzing our ptas
so there's what's called either region
graph which is
useful for it's like proving our
decidability
it's like results but it's it's
exponential in it's like it's like size
so it isn't so useful in
it's like practice and then we've
i've developed a a number of zone-based
approaches where you sort of take the
pta
and then you build a finite state
mdp by sort of
traversing through the pta
and you build the states of the um
mdp and then our location and
zone pair so it's sort of a symbolic
state
that represents
all of the our location
clock evaluation pairs where the select
valuation satisfies the
slight zone so there's a
number of approaches so the first was
using forward
it's like reachability and this gave
only a
it's like upper bounds on some maximum
reachability
it's like it's like probabilities we've
since
extended that to allow
optimal select reachability
probabilities so this is both
minimum and it's like maximum it's like
reachability
probabilities and this was through a
game-based abstraction and
refinement slight approach
but it doesn't introduce what are called
non-convex
zones which means that it it's it can
slow it down in
practice there's also the dual
approach based on it's like backwards
slight reachability and here you can
compute
so optimal both probabilities and
expected it's like rewards
for rewards and
it's at the minimum case it does again
we get
non-convex zones which can slow things
down and for
our rewards we also need to move from
it's like instagram constants in the
zones to
it's like rational ones which obviously
means that it's going to be
of less use in select practice so that's
just to say
that there are these ones there and if
you're interested i can
give you more details on these
so finally onto partially observable
it's like ptas so here we've got an even
longer it's like tuple but the first
part is just
a our pta that we've it's like
it's like already seen and all that's
new is that we now have a set of
observations and then a a function that
says if i'm in a
our location what can i observe
so it's like for a upon dp
but here it isn't what can i observe
when i'm in a state
it's what i can observe when i'm in a
our location and similarly to
upon dps if if two
our locations are observably
the same then they have to have the same
invariance and slight enabling
slight conditions for all so actions as
otherwise
they wouldn't be a strategy could
tell them apart
okay so it's like under this
we get a uncountably
it's like it's like infinite state pom
dp
as the our semantics so the
transition and reward functions or
are as i gave for ptas
and for the observations if i'm in
a state of the which is a
a location clock evaluation pair then i
observe what i observe of the location
and i get to see all the clocks okay so
notice
all clocks are
it's like it's like visible now you
could or
we have so i started to or we did start
to consider
the place where some of the clocks are
hidden but that makes things even more
are complicated
as you would need sort of a
second slight player to
select deal with the these it's like
other
looks like clocks and then you'd have to
move to partially
observable two-player games which are
even harder to solve them
select pom dps now
what we've shown is that under the
following
looks like slight restrictions um
then it's like the digital clocks
semantics
so it preserves the it's like
probabilistic and
it's like expected it's like
reachability it's the values of a
partially observable
it's like it's like pta so the zones
have to be closed and it's slight
diagonal free so that's the same as
such ptas and four times automata and
then
so we also need that resets can only be
applied to clocks that are non zero
why is this so needed will
so otherwise clock slip resets
can be used to differentiate
between our locations so say that we had
probabilistic edges going two to two
observably equivalent are locations
where only one of the edges reset a
slight clock which we can obviously see
then if we have real valued clocks
then a our strategy could be able to
tell
the a difference at
essentially no it's like cost it could
let an arbitrary
small slight amount of time pass so that
it
so that a clock was it's like greater
than a zero
and then if it took the just like
transition
then it could tell it's like the
difference
swept between the two our locations
while
in the our digital clocks so you have to
let you would have to let either zero or
it's like one
time unit passed if it was zero that
wouldn't help you to
it's like it's like differentiate so for
the real
valued and it's like the digital clocks
to be
equivalent you need this our condition
here
but um so just to say that both of these
are
easy to check syntactically on the
rpta so we have the
our semantics of a partially observable
our ptta is a infinite state upon dp
we can then use the digital clocks
if these our conditions are true then we
can
construct and essentially it's like
equivalent
finite state just like select from dp
and then we can use the our techniques
from the first half
of the talk and get upper and
our lower bounds and also do the our
refinement
of the grid if we
wanted to okay i'll finally quickly
start mentioning
sort of implementation but given the
time i'll um
skip the select case studies okay so
just to say that this is now part of the
um main branch of our prism now so
you can now do the analysis of both our
pomdps and
partially observable our ptas using
these
uh our methods and certainly google of
google's summer of code was used there
was a
intern that did it's like some of this
um and just to say how this
works is that we have this fixed grid
from
other literature that's very unnaive
so it's given so this is the grid of
resolution that i was
like using when i was running up
prism so you just set some you choose
your m
and then this gives you these grid
points here
and a our benefit or
it's like why we chose to do that is
then it's easy or easy
to find are the constants gamma 1
up to gamma n given any arbitrary
belief and this is as i showed you that
this was needed during value it's like
iteration
and a our downside as well as this being
a
naive slight approach is also
if you increase m then the grid points
grow
exponentially and we could certainly try
to improve that
slight efficiency with more are complex
it's like grids and trying to vary them
based on the beliefs that we actually
encountered during value
it's like iteration okay so i'll i'll
keep
i'll skip the
select case studies and i'll just i'll
conclude so
what i've introduced are models that
have
non-determinism real time probability
and
partial observability
and at the start i i tried to motivate
but these are
required except for many real world
slight case studies
and there's a lot that we could do to
improve things so as i've said we've
only presented a very
simple solution a method
and there's many more advanced
techniques for
finding it's like different except
values
that we could probably try to adapt to
um here
for the real-time side i
so we used the digital clocks
semantics we could look into using
symbolic
our techniques um
both in terms of our bdds and in terms
of
slightly zones which and zones have
proved to be
more so efficient than
it's like digital clocks in so many are
cases
and obviously one big limitation
is that all the clocks are observable so
it would be good to
move to a case where some of them
slept weren't but as a and
there has been some sort of work on this
in the non
uh our probabilistic case so this is for
this is for time
automata partially observable timed
automata but you would have to move to
it's like games and as i've said
things get more it's like complicated
there
okay so i'll finish then and i'll open
up to any
uh slight select questions
thank you very much for uh the really
nice tutorial getting
thank you let me first open the floor
for
some questions if someone has you can
type them or
raise hand
and uh if not maybe then i will do uh
something that
actually would really like to know more
about case studies if you could you
don't really need to go through
everyone i can see nodding everyone
would if you
don't need to go through all the details
but maybe just give us a flavor
of uh you know like on which properties
did you prove out for the real world
systems and
okay i can i can but that's why i said
look if there's some questions please
shout out because i would really like to
knock your
studies okay so we first so there's
so there's one that was sort of based on
um a wireless
scheduling of a packet so so here
so you can't tell it's like it's like
the state of
our channels because if you did try to
find them out then that would slow
things down because and it comes
at a a cost so
we looked at sort of what was the
maximum
number sort of how to minimize
it's like the number of packets that
were dropped or to
it's like maximize a a slight reward
and that our reward was sort of based on
so the number of packets sent but also
some of the
some of the packets had higher our
priority so they had a higher
it's like reward so we looked at them
because we could ask
did you have some uh
probabilistic or stochastic uh uh
requirement
at which rate the packets are coming in
or is was it uh
yeah so we so it was a probabilistic
as to if a packet would come in at each
sort of at the beginning of each time
slot and also it was
a probabilistic as to if it was a low or
medium or high
a packet and then also
the behavior of other channel was
are probabilistic so it could sort of
like go
go down or sort of so that it wasn't
always
operational but what we found was
some of the time it was good to not
actually send
so anything and just to watch to see
what
our state the our channels
we're in and then and then you can use
that to make sure that the high
our priority um our packets
do do get sent which obviously therefore
gives you a bigger
a reward and you might lose out on some
of the lower ones
so that was one of the case studies
like the second one was when when
a person was so there was sort of
there's two
are people one was high and one was sort
of
high or security and one was low and the
high
high person was trying to get eight
it's like secret to the low person just
by
are delaying
select messages but it was
but to try to stop this
it was put through a a buffer so
as things came in to be sent then they'd
be sort of
then a a random our delay would be
so added to them to try and hide
or to try and stop high from are
transmitting this
so it was to see how
effective they some was so could
low guess other value after sort of
after seeing the uh our delays
that had been sort of
it's like randomized so obviously if you
add in a
it's like really big a delay then even
if you
add in more time so if you try to add in
sort of a a probabilistic part to the
to the short one then you have to add in
a huge
delay to sort of hide hide the fact
so does that make sense for that one and
then there were two other ones
one was sort of task or scheduling
and uh
so you couldn't see if a um if a
a process was are sleeping or just
idling because if you wake it up from
sleep then that is a much bigger cost
than if you if it was idling
and then so the final one was a
non uh our
repudiation our protocol so here you've
got sort of
the recipient is trying to get some
information from the originator but it
it can't see it all until it's until
it's all been sent so it's
fair to both our parties
and this needs both timing and
uh it's not probabilistic
it's like values
okay thank you for uh showing this and
are there more questions that i think
that really kind of gave us also better
uh feeling uh about the properties that
can be proven the systems that can be
modeled
more questions
orina sorry you have a hands up please
yes i have a question
uh about uh the on the type of uh
so in in the in the case studies that
were that you considered
uh did you have uh situations where it
was unnatural to assume that clocks are
observable
and you had to model around that or
no but
actually it's it's
it's hard to know because i knew that
clocks were
observable when i was choosing which are
case studies i was going to look at so
there are certainly are cases where
you'd want the clocks to be
are hidden but there's also are cases
where
it's really not a problem so so
in the case that
[Music]
but it would be great to i'll be able to
do that because
it would certainly add or something new
so and in terms of the other
restrictions that you had on the on the
shape of the
automata of the
they didn't that wasn't an issue
so and and if i may ask one more
question
so uh about the so you mentioned about
uh
kind of more sophisticated approaches uh
for uh choosing the these representative
beliefs
so is there already some kind of uh like
good heuristics that are being employed
or uh it's still uh
there are in other planning and ai
worlds but
it's sort of in but there they there
they've got a different
a problem because there they often they
just
they either look at sort of over they
have a
fixed or time bound and
if you think about that then you're only
going to
encounter our finitely many
our beliefs if you only do finitely many
states
and then all the issues about
undecidability
go away whereas in the verification sort
of
community so we're most of the time we
seem to be all
so the focus is on sort of unbounded or
our properties and there it's are
different
but there are are certain things from
from there which i think can be used
to um help because it seems clear that
this
it's like grid-based thing it's sort of
it's only if the beliefs
that you want are it's like close
to the grid points then it then it can
work well
but if they're far away then it
doesn't work well so if you can choose
your it's like grid points
so they're close to the beliefs that you
see then
or you see with a high a probability
more importantly
i think than it then that can really
help
i mean i guess another difference is
that in in planning and oftentimes you
have
you know like some kind of numerical
reward while like
from a verification perspective you
might have your property expressed on
like on a higher level that you have
compiled down to uh
to a reward and that might help in terms
of uh
kind of doing some analysis from the
point of view of verification techniques
identifying what would be a
good thing yeah yeah
okay thanks okay i have to stop here
because we are out of time and
i know that we are all in different time
zones so i want to really thank you
uh well i see we have superity who is in
india whom whom is right now middle of
the night
we have to stick to the schedule so
thank you very much once more getting
for
this really nice and informative
tutorial it
was a very interesting for all of us and
uh
i'll see you all tomorrow so thank you
once again thank you thanks a lot
thank you bye everyone
bye bye
you